meantime a story we brought you justices
on the US Supreme Court will decide
whether a cross on public land in
Maryland constitutes an illegal
endorsement of religion by the
government Fox News chief legal
correspondent and anchor of fox news at
night shannon bream tells us about
today's arguments it saddens me actually
to be here standing before you veterans
from across the country showed up at the
Supreme Court today fighting to preserve
a 40-foot high world war one Memorial in
the shape of a cross it was built with
private funds in an effort headed by the
American Legion a century ago an atheist
group has spent years fighting to get
rid of the cross in Maryland which
originally sat on a plot of private land
that has since been transferred to
government ownership critics say that
entanglement of government and religion
is unconstitutional
while advocates for the so called peace
cross say it's a secular war memorial
today
Justice Kagan said many see it as much
more quote it is the foremost symbol of
Christianity isn't it it invokes the
central theological claim of
Christianity that Jesus Christ the Son
of God died on the cross for Humanity
since and while opponents of the
monument argue the government sends a
message of endorsement for Christianity
by maintaining the cross-shaped Memorial
Justice Alito asked about the
alternative about other public monuments
with potential religious symbolism how
they must be handled if quote we say you
got to take down all of the crosses what
message does that send when people see
that on TV they see crosses all over the
country being knocked down today the
steel beams left behind in the wake of
9/11 which many viewed as it crossed
like symbol got a lot of attention from
the justices provoking questions about
where exactly the court should draw the
line on government involved displays
involving religious imagery justice
Gorsuch said today this is one of the
only situations in which people are
allowed to sue over something like this
because it offends them adding we have
to find a way to tolerate each other a
decision is due by late June Brett
Shannon thank you see you tonight at
11:00